today i'd like to introduce you to the
new super smash brothers game for the
nintendo switch
as you may know super smash brothers is
an action game about smashing beloved
game characters off the screen
many fighters have appeared in this
series i'm sure you're
all eager to find out who will be
joining the roster this time
so we made a video to showcase some
fighters appearing in the game
the number next to each fighter
signifies the order in which they joined
the super smash brothers series
please take a look
[Music]
yahoo
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
what
[Music]
that's right every fighter in super
smash brothers history
is joining the battle
[Music]
indeed absolutely every super smash
brothers fighter
ever is in this game whether they were
originally dlc
or only appeared once in the past we
believe that's what players want
so we made the impossible possible
any way you slice it this one has the
most smash for your buck
simply put this is the biggest crossover
in gaming history
once again world will collide
even so your starting roster may be as
small as the original nintendo 64 game
we've streamlined the conditions for
unlocking fighters and we want to make
the process
interesting so it feels like you're
constantly recruiting popular characters
to your side
eight player battles are also making a
return
see what happens when you hit many
different fighters against one another
now let's take a closer look at certain
fighters by highlighting how they've
changed since their last appearance
mario's still easy to use but we did add
a little something
for someone from his latest adventure he
can also wear his wedding and builder
outfits
[Music]
link dons as champions tunic from the
legend of zelda breath of the wild
his bombs are now remotely detonated
and his final smash unleashes ancient
arrows
he can also wear link's familiar tunic
of the wild
although it's been a while the
two-in-one fighter the ice climbers
are back work together with nana
once she's gone you're in serious
trouble
ike's outfit from fire emblem path of
radiance returns
along with his look from fire emblem
radiant dawn now you can use both
versions for the first time
the two different versions are even
voiced a little differently prepare
yourself
prepare yourself
[Music]
we now have the female version of
pikachu complete with a heart-shaped
tail
did you notice pikachu libre is a girl
[Music]
fox's design is now based on star fox
zero and his final smash has received an
overhaul
this time final smashes are straight to
the point so you can get right back to
fighting
falco's final smash features an
unorthodox ship formation that's more
unruly than fox's
either way the landmaster has been
retired
in one-on-one fights ryu will always
face his opponents
just like in his original game
appearances
it's a small touch that reduces
accidental command inputs
charge moves like samus's charge shot
can now power up in midair
you can cancel with jump or dodge but
you'll be open to attack
marth's dancing blade is faster and it's
easier to unleash
one after another this holds true for
roy and lucina too
in addition marth is now fully voiced in
english
keep your eyes open
[Music]
back by popular demand veteran fighter
snake is sneaking back into the fray
it's been 10 years since his last
appearance in the series so we can
finally make some new dream matches come
true
of course shadow moses island is back
too
king ddd's final smash is basically a
cage fight where he unleashes
missiles and a jet hammer
pichu is also returning from super smash
brothers melee
its electric shock still damaged itself
too so be careful
in the legend of zelda breath of the
wild zelda is more into research than
fighting so her design is from the
legend of zelda a link between worlds
zelda is much more elegant regal than
our other fighters but we made sure you
wouldn't underestimate her energetic
attacks
her final smash is a ceiling move called
triforce of
wisdom
sonic's final smash supersonic is more
souped up than ever
either you're too slow or he's lightning
fast
pac-man also got a speed boost this time
around
looping around the stage sounds just
like pac-man don't you think
pokemon trainer is back with squirtle
ivysaur and charizard
you can change pokemon during battle and
this time there's no penalty for
sticking with one so feel free to pick
your main
also you can play as a female trainer
for the first time
some fighters like captain falcon
trigger a dramatic slow-mo effect
on strong attacks in one-on-one fights
and of course his hazardous big blue
stage is making a return
just like before you can play as cloud
in his final fantasy vii costume or his
final fantasy vii advent children
costume
now you can see his limit gage near his
damage percentage at all times
special displays are available for
certain other fighters too
for example
[Music]
you can see how much longer robin can
use leaven sword and tomes
[Music]
for villager we made it easier to see
what you've pocketed
between the male and female versions
there are eight different villagers
bowser's final smash gigabowser is even
bigger
and better he's now as big as bowser
from the yoshi's island game
all of mr gaiman watch's moves are back
and he looks even more like he did in
his original games
his transformations are more full of
character than ever
youngling from super smash brothers
melee is making a comeback
that makes three links for the first
time
long long milk anyone
after 10 long years wolfe makes his
return his design is based on starbucks
zero and each of his moves have received
a significant
upgrade
[Music]
kirby is his usual puffy self
but we've added a little something to
his stone ability
he has a copy ability for every fighter
so the more fighters we have the more
challenging he becomes to develop
shelf used to require repeated button
presses to toggle monado arms
but now you can choose a specific one
with a button press and a quick
directional tilt
sure is handy to change arts on slides
[Applause]
we also added fiora to his final smash
ganondorf rises again returning to his
popular design from the legend of zelda
ocarina of time and for his final smash
he becomes demon king again
knee fighter's proportions have been
tweaked a bit
there are three types brawler sword
fighter
and gunner the moveset for each type has
also been enhanced
and you can now choose from 12 voice
options
we're hoping to get this fighter ready
for online play
previously pitt's final smash has three
sacred treasures
this time he'll be riding in style on
the lightning chariot
in the last game zero suit samus final
smash called in her gunship
this time she uses her power suit to
fire a devastating laser
when olimar gets damaged you'll see a
crack in his helmet
but don't worry it'll get fixed up right
away
[Music]
bayonetta's costumes from her first two
games are both available
listen closely and you'll hear
differences in the sound effects
it seems we have a guest
rodon appears as an assist trophy
[Music]
warrior's final smash warrior man has
changed quite a bit
after transforming he no longer uses
individual attacks to get the job done
[Music]
donkey kong's final smash is all rabbit
fire punches like donkey kong jungle
people
you'll notice that he and other fighters
have expressive new facial animations
[Music]
little max final smash is now a rush of
blows from gigamax
in fact all final smash moves in the
game get right to the punch
ness's new final smash calls on paula
and poo
of course jeff still shows up as an
assist trophy
likewise lucas's final smash features
kumatora
and boney
at first glance refit trainer seems the
same but her face has a new look i
wavered a bit on whether to change it
but it was a request from the wii hit
developers
[Music]
we've included all the hazards from both
versions of mega man stage from super
smash brothers for wii u
and nintendo 3ds
and for his final smash say hello to
protoman
and bass
[Music]
palutena's special attacks have been
streamlined this time around
and her down specimen is now both a
counter and a deflector
rob has a new gauge on his chassis
showing how much fuel he has left for
hovering
[Music]
notice the epsilon symbols next to
lucina and darkpit's numbers
each of these fighters are based on
another fighter in the game we're
treating these fighters a little
differently and have decided to call
them echo fighters
allow me to introduce a brand new echo
fighter
daisy joins a roster as peach's echo
fighter
she fights in a similar manner as peach
but they have different characteristics
which we hope you'll enjoy
have fun playing as your favorite
princesses
all in all if you add up the changes
we're making there could be tens of
thousands
i hope you're looking forward to some
serious matchups
and here's a new fighter
[Music]
inkling is a completely new addition to
the roster
if you ink opponents they'll take more
damage from attacks
different weapons are available as smash
attacks or special attacks
the splatter shot splat bomb
splat roller and the final smash
killer whale
you can actually run out of ink so it's
important to refill by pressing the b
button while shielding
inkling boy also debuts alongside
inkling girl
inklings are very fashionable all eight
have their own
outfits and each has their own ink color
so matches get really bright
by the way we added in the squid sisters
as an assist trophy
during their live concert the camera
zooms in for a close-up
that means it's easier to get knocked
off the screen
[Applause]
while we're on the topic of assist
trophies let me share some additional
information
as you may know assist trophies lend
helpful support in battles
you can ko assist trophies by inflicting
damage and now
you get points for it too
[Music]
however some assist trophies will remain
unbeatable
maybe an unexpected guest will photobomb
your battle
yup it's him
there's a wide variety more than 50 of
them here in the game
[Music]
[Applause]
of course we're also adding even more
pokemon and items
we can't wait to show you
[Music]
there are a variety of stages available
in this game as well
including a massive list of returning
stages if you get a group together to
play
it'll be a challenge to hit them all the
graphics have been improved as well
let's get a look at some stages from
various games
[Music]
so
me so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all stages now have both battlefield and
omega forms too
these versions hover above an abyss
their sizes and terrain are all the same
so savor the simplicity with music and
background from your favorite series
let's take a sneak peek at the new and
returning techniques you can pull off
during battles
[Music]
the directional air dodge enhances
mobility
it can come in handy when recovering
from a fall
however if you dodge too much even on
the ground you'll be wide open to attack
and your duration of intangibility gets
shorter
[Music]
you can execute short hop attacks by
pressing the a button and jump at any
time
also you can smash attack by pressing
the a and b buttons
just like the previous game
[Music]
a perfect shield occurs when you release
the shield button
until now you were able to pull it off
without any major risks but going
forward you'll need to time it carefully
for one-on-one battles the damage dealt
will now be greater than
in battles with higher numbers of
players
this should help ensure that the action
is well paced
in a timed battle the fighter and the
lead will sometimes flash with light
better do something or no victory pose
for you
we've got something special for your
playing pleasure in super smash brothers
ultimate
[Music]
nintendo gamecube controllers can be
used in super smash brothers ultimate
for many of you it just isn't the same
without them
not to mention all super smash brothers
series amiibo figures are compatible
this time as well
[Music]
in fact all fighters current amiibo
figures will be supported
even if they're from a different series
tap a compatible amiibo figure to add in
a figure player or fp
and level up your fp data from previous
titles can be transferred
we hope you're as excited as we are our
staff will continue working hard
until the game releases we really
appreciate your support
we've made including every single
fighter ever our number one
goal so i'm kind of hoping you aren't
expecting too many new challengers
however we do have one more announcement
please
take a look
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you